gehört sie mit den und ich bin da in
sachsen schweizer aussenministerium hat
der reise war nicht lustig woche und ich
bin da muss ich finde
ob es wirklich so schlimm ist
[Musik]
si
jetzt nicht gefällt wie gefährlich
würden sie sagen ist dresden
das kader von 145
[Musik]
deutschland ist ein schönes land weil
man hier schicken kann
aber alles was würden sie dresslers
gefährlich einschätzen
es kommt darauf an wo man hingeht und an
welchem wochentag menschen mit
migrationshintergrund oder die halt eben
so aussehen als wären sie nicht deutsch
wie sie es immer so schön sagen kann ich
mir schon vorstellen dass sie sich
montags amt nicht auf die straße trauen
dies jetzt auch in chemnitz der fall ist
also ist es für schweizer ungefährlich
solange sie deutsch aussehen könnte man
glaube ich so sagen was ist deutsch ja
was würden sie mir raten wie sehe ich
noch ein bisschen deutsch aus schwer
zwischen wenig eigentlich muss zum typ
wirklich wenn ich mache schon recht gute
job der monte waren ist es am
gefährlichsten
heute abend weil die damen und herren
und die wiederum sprühen
[Musik]
wir haben ein hammer ziehen hier auf dem
platz die sich bei uns nicht angemeldet
hat
wir wissen aber die sind von der cd
freut sich schon
[Applaus]
kinder bärischen ortsversammlung ich
empfinde deutschland wirklich als sehr
zäh lixfeld wie bisher sind sie aus
trist aber sie sind chemnitzer ja
wirklich stehen teil haben wir für die
chemnitzer ja das war echt schrecklich
was da passiert ist als die toten hosen
gekommen sind ich dachte mir das ist
übel herr das ist wirklich schlimmste
was man in deutschland bieten können
sich irgendjemand als nazi scherge
niemand und ich habe aber auch nicht von
nazis gesprochen
ich sag mir so nah weil ja offiziell das
immer so gesagt wird ja also der herr
zeit dass da in deutschland kein ort
sind was macht den dresdner aus also wie
könnte ich mich ich bin ja schweizerin
wie könnte ich mich besser integrieren
hier
sie brauchen sich dann nicht integriert
die braucht nur als normaler mensch ihr
leben damit wenn ich abends aus afrika
wäre dann wäre das nicht jeder flüge es
gibt auch leute aus afrika die nachts um
drei uhr nachts um vier oder fünf filme
durch die straßen gehen
rauschgift verkaufen leute überfallen
und klauen und dessen ausländer ist
daher als asylbewerber kommis der fliegt
bei mir nächsten tag ist er wieder in
der sahara da wir schon voll ist
demokratisches recht wenn ein rentner
der als asylbewerber gekommen ist dann
schmeiß ich los da bin locker sodann ich
mache was jeder mensch machen würde
also liebe schweizerinnen und schweizer
die heime falls sie gedanken in dresden
gibt es verkaufen und dann morgen sollte
ich eigentlich ziemlich ungewöhnlich ich
hab's schweizerin hat er unter zu
patriotisch zu sein warum sind sie als
deutscher auch patriotische gut weil ich
deutscher eltern habe deutsche großvater
alles deutsch in bayerischer abstammung
bayerisches kulturgut genau
wir sagen wir so historischen schweizer
ist aber bei uns heißt die bayern mir
san mir
und wir müssen so deutschland stehen
oder bei uns heißt ob schweiz kanada und
rosenhof
[Musik]
also wirklich süd kunde aberglauben
erstes auftreten ist am ristic und damit
zurück ins studio
[Musik]